hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel today i'm gonna be doing
something a little different i've been
told
i need to educate myself and learn more
about the hood and gangs and whatever
so i decided to react
to a video that i saw come up on my
youtube channel
or like on my youtube suggested part um
of you guys you guys know what i'm
saying okay so it said
chicago engel inglewood hood
interview with neighborhood gang
um i've never
listened to this before and i don't know
anything about
gangs i am from the suburbs but
i'm about to learn so you guys can watch
me learn
but before i start this video do not
forget
to subscribe again trying to make a
career out of this and the more
subscribers i have the more motivated i
am to keep pushing out content to keep
making stuff for you
so every subscriber really helps half of
you guys watching my videos
don't even subscribe what is that about
i don't get it i don't get it
leave a comment leave a like let me know
did i get it right did i get it wrong
yeah because people like people oh man
okay okay i know these other guys back
here i know they want to get their names
or whatever
well i'm gonna ask you all the questions
that people always ask me and i want to
know my i live in detroit but
like uh chicago famous for their gangs
y'all known for y'all organized gangs i
remember
what's the name of the most like
prominent gangs in chicago
like disciples
uh what kind in this this dislike the
englewood section of the south side
right
yeah so what kind of get real right here
what kind of games in this area
money black [ __ ] money little more there
ain't nobody know
oh okay still that's how it goes real
regular [ __ ] even
okay now i've never heard of any of that
i know like in uh um
now do y'all have like if you want to
see gangs do you see gangs like standing
on the street
do they wear the same clothes like
though
right right that that's it yeah because
people
like people like detroit got you know
some games too but people always ask me
well how come i don't see games they
think they stand on the street like
bandanas on the head like nobody do that
no more
okay so i'm learning right now that
gangs
do not have matching outfits so me and
my friends
go out sometimes we like to coordinate
outfits we'll text each other say what
are you wearing
what it like try to coordinate an outfit
so but what i'm hearing is that
gangs do not do that oh bro don't nobody
doing that [ __ ] man that [ __ ] old days
man
yeah like now that games is low key
people low key
and and i know in detroit they low key
and what they do is
they like they they form a gang and they
do certain things together they might
commit crimes together or whatever but
they don't stand on the corner
and you know what i said should hit you
right i know i want to tweak it on
stones
what is that
on this [ __ ] man this [ __ ] can't be
made shorty
all y'all from this neighborhood around
here
um
[ __ ] that [ __ ] don't mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] know who they want you
ain't going back there
[ __ ] know who they want all
that clothes and [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't
mean [ __ ] out here
that [ __ ] don't mean [ __ ] at all so i
agree
like i don't think it really matters
what you wear um
like i think super expensive clothes are
kind of a waste of money
so i think he's saying like that it
doesn't matter what you wear it matters
the type of person you are
and i would agree like that makes sense
to me yeah
you know we just trying to get the hold
up get this paper
that's the only thing you can't do
unless these [ __ ] won't smoke
you know okay so he's saying that
they're just trying to make money unless
you want to smoke
i don't i'm not a smoker and i'm sick of
people on this channel
saying that i look high i'm not high
it's just my face
now adjust this a little bit okay and
but like for the most part i think he's
just saying we get money
and we
smoke weed okay okay so like now why
don't we get into
um y'all want to talk about y'all what's
up
whole so he just casually pulls out an
automatic weapon from under the stairs
oh dear okay okay
we out
been a whole lot of [ __ ] going on
[ __ ] get on off this [ __ ] for
real
even man
shout out young charlie man most
valuable player mvp underscore young
charlie
mvp so it looks like they like to watch
basketballs
that's cool okay that's what yeah
money block [ __ ] so earth
so i think they're like scoping out cars
because i i've heard about drive-bys and
i don't
know a lot about them but i think it's
like when the rival gang comes by and
will shoot at you so i think that's why
they had
the gun under the stairs
and like that's why they're looking at
the car
male eight miles seven mile what [ __ ]
that being downtown greek town shout out
everybody shout out you know a little
bit about detroit man
hey i told you i am not a fan of how low
their pants are
i know this is gonna people are gonna
comment that's like a typical white
person thing to say but like i don't
i don't want to see your boxers i don't
think we're on that level yeah like
that's kind of weird
i did an interview with me yesterday you
did an interview with me yesterday
and i had a detroit on what you was that
you were in chicago
370 miles away you've been this [ __ ]
real right here bro straight facts hey
i'm gonna split it that's how i'm coming
up
already out go look at that [ __ ] link
that [ __ ] already
share y'all we just down here whole gang
[ __ ] you know this ain't no other city
i see you better [ __ ] baltimore
i think everything i've been born every
place you have been across the world man
i like that man you taking this [ __ ] to
the heart and i like people that
put it to the full effect that's what
people want to see they want to see
people from the neighborhood they want
you to just show the neighborhood they
want to talk to the people and find out
what's going on what the neighborhood is
like and all that kind of stuff was
what's wrong with the neighborhood
what's right with the neighborhood
what's wrong with the neighborhood with
the neighborhood there's a lot of people
on this campus
with the neighborhood man well we trying
to talk don't understand us man i'm
locked in the system they don't
understand
[Music]
okay so he's saying that he's actually
seen someone get shot that's
that's so sad they don't really look
that old either
you're real y'all this [ __ ] thinking it
all left we just don't want to say that
[ __ ] we know people
interested in that [ __ ] but it's a lot
of [ __ ] that can't be seen in this [ __ ]
you feel me
like i like you saying gay [ __ ] all
we do this [ __ ] together to get out bro
in the d
got the d locked down we taking trips he
making i got the d
locked down alabama you catch me in
miami all that [ __ ] we doing this [ __ ]
man where you just came from but we just
going on 20 on the top
see they always hold like wads of cash
in the videos i've been watching
too that guy is a lot of cash and
they're talking about like traveling
going on tour maybe hey you're like bro
bro
some public [ __ ] be focusing me but my
manager said i can't publish it right
now
i don't know what reason but you know
he's saying stage behind it you know but
it's kind of strong man
wanted me to be in the game but it's my
environment this [ __ ] got me like this
you feel me okay which game you
if you want to say oh no chop the city
chunky city i'm
okay so let me okay what what okay so
he's in the game
i'm gonna take you to my end and see how
that [ __ ] is this
this [ __ ] all the same [ __ ] though we
gotta be on every kind
rad pass
every car that rides we gotta be on that
[ __ ]
okay so they have to i think that's what
i was saying earlier so every car that
comes by they have to make sure it's not
someone trying to shoot them
we call that compass we got to be on
these cars because people like to
attempt what y'all thinks about the
drive pass
start shooting or something that's the
that's the key and then
[ __ ] y'all y'all got people out there
y'all i got people after y'all that want
to get y'all
this whole chicago awards on look you
see how every
you ain't noticed every car that ruled
past my real surreal that's how we gotta
live bro
you think this [ __ ] is sweet is it how
you gotta live us how you wanna live
so i wonder why they have to live like
that because
like there's no one putting a gun to
your head i don't think in making you
join a gang and it looks like they don't
even want to be in a gang
but he's trying to rap and like get out
of it so i'm just curious as to like why
he has to people nemesis
did the city like i know back because i
got a partner in detroit he used to live
in one of some of the old projects
did the city get better or worse when
they tore down all them old cabrini
greens and robert taylor and all that
stuff
they put everybody all through the area
all through the hood when they put down
the product they gave my father's fake
dreams
false hopes telling my father the
project is going to be back straight the
process ain't been straight since it's
white people in that business bills
through the roof [ __ ] all
through the blocks of [ __ ] now englewood
out west everything [ __ ] yeah that was
like at one point
the biggest housing project in the uh in
the country it's a lot of them though
you know
scattered down state street state yeah
statewide gardens and robert taylor
and what's the other ones over there a
lot of them [ __ ] bro there's so many
committee greens
all the [ __ ] bro the community greens
on the north side though wasn't it but
it's so big i don't know what they're
talking about
there's so many projects out here they
just tuned
it looks like they were tearing down
like bad buildings and it didn't
actually help their community like it
made it worse or like
other communities started to move in put
the people out here
if you grow up in this neighborhood are
you better off in a gang or not in the
game you got to be you got it you ain't
going to be
on games you don't get your ass [ __ ]
that's how you take it type [ __ ] man
you know because you grew up right here
people from right here and the [ __ ] yo
people shooting and killing you feeling
dude you can't walk the street and they
love brother them they on your ass
regardless they your brother don't they
gonna whoop you all type of [ __ ] so what
you gonna do just sit back here now
you're gonna love
your brother he's my brother we didn't
lose brothers all type of [ __ ] let's be
my boy
so he's saying that
it was worth like because he said are
you
better or worse being in a gang so he's
saying
that it's almost better in some ways
because otherwise you have to watch your
friends get killed and stuff
and you don't like if that happens
like what are you gonna do just like
watch it happen and not do anything
about it
all that [ __ ] we all have man we ain't
playing around with you this [ __ ] for
real bro when we say this [ __ ] for real
just like you've been in a lot of space
they they really
live every car that rap has you really
got to be
who who's in these cars well i know how
chicago is about the gang stuff
they got a reputation for that yeah i
know a lot of games
bro
it's so [ __ ] up on that trying
they all like that stuff like the
gangster disciples and the black
disciples they still
they got that stuff yeah oh yeah that
[ __ ] means something
don't really mean nothing just block
this your brother like you beating your
family
crying black stones that's what i
okay um i think i'm gonna end it
instead of going through the entire
thing so that was an
interesting video uh took a lot of turns
um gave me a lot of insights um i never
thought about having to like
watch every car as you walk as they come
by to see if someone's gonna shoot you
that's
that's crazy to me i can't even imagine
people
drive by all the time in my neighborhood
nobody even looks twice
if you liked this type of reaction let
me know in the comments would you
do you prefer this type of reaction or
do you prefer